I think the thing that I did that that
worked out for me best
was I just stayed patient and I never
I never took the
the you know they dangle to carrot in
front of your face you know I mean or
whatever thing is like I never took the
club never went out to the shiny object
exactly meaning like
I just always felt like I was always
hesitant to do
what was being offered you know I mean
although it might you know for instance
and and I think in uh in rap or maybe
it's music period but like you have a
successful album
they want to renegotiate right away and
the artist is like
yeah I do that because you're gonna get
another million boom yeah they want to
renegotiate but it's like they're gonna
tack on how many albums for that so it's
like I was like oh I got these
successful albums I'm gonna chill
I'm not going to just renegotiate I'm
good on that boom boom and the longer I
waited
the better my leverage played out for me
when it came time you know it's like no
and I'll still apply that to this day
I'm like I'm I'm very slow to do those
types of deals because I'm like yo
I don't know yet let me fill this out
wow you know I mean let me take a little
more time and the more time you take the
more the more the truth starts to show
itself you know what I mean it's like so
I'm I I can't really sit here like some
Mojo and give business advice because I
don't think I run like the the best
business I'm grateful to have great
people around me where it's like my
money good boom boom you know I mean I'm
smart with my money you know I mean like
I always and that's just come from fears
like I don't never ever want to be broke
again so I'm slow to like Frugal or or
just mindful which one
what's the difference a Frugal means you
don't spin because you're a cheap
ass
mindful means yeah I'll Splurge I'll
treat myself there's things that I do no
no yeah I would definitely say mindful
okay because I'll if it's the right
thing if it's a vacation you know I mean
family vacation one more I'm gonna spend
you know I mean like if it's a
if it's uh no I'm not afraid to spend
but but I'm mindful where it's like yeah
I think mindful is the word you know I
mean and it helps there's like bro I
don't I don't
I'm not I don't really K like I'm a hard
person to get a gift for because I don't
it's not like I have everything I got
every car boom boom it's like if you got
me a car I would be like oh man he got
me a car you know what I mean like he
don't know I don't care about the car
camera yeah man you know what I mean
like oh like you got me a watch like
damn this expensive it's going to put it
up yeah in my heart I'm like bro so it
helps that I I don't really that allows
me to go a little harder over here you
know I remember I caught you with the
socks you just had the remember you had
the the socks out the pack and I said
Jay what there they go God damn
God damn he was on me you know I think
about you often God damn I wear these
socks these like like yellow toe socks
bro I I just had to take them off to
keep it real bro like we was we were
shooting a video Kevin seen myself
and he he was like I remember you was
like a
you know there's better socks right I
remember I looked at you because I was
like
yeah you know that you know there's of
higher level you need a better quality
sock than that like I know where that
sock is from he's like I like these you
just kept I remember you kept doing this
I like these
just so I know those are the ones that's
like six in the pack right yeah yeah
what do you spend it on what's the
Splurge okay vacation what is the
problem is that it uh
yeah like some stupid video game setup
or something no no no no but I'm about
to get that I just got into the VR uh
yeah I can see I can see I'm gonna be a
house you got a room can't put these on
yeah it's like a suit what else there's
got to be something what's the thing
um no no no no no no no no like on I
mean on a consistent basis or like I
built a studio in the crib but that was
a lot okay I mean that's good I got a
gym at a crib that's good all right so
those are those are like
personal growth spaces in both of them
things like that you're you're investing
into things where you can get a return
out of the studio and the house is dope
whenever I want to go down I can go down
I'm in the comfort of my home gym and
the house I can go work out whenever I
want a basketball court a basketball
court okay that's dope it's like I could
just hoop anytime drive to the Lifetime
Fitness I ain't got a boom
exactly okay that makes sense then
vacations I I can't really sit here and
and
I like that you don't though I like I
like that you are you sure I'm the
jackass with the the stupid hobbies and
the things like that that I've got into